aujourd'hui est un grand jour est encore
plus grand qui hier premièrement j'ai
appris que johnny crying était l'auteur
de la vidéo des quenouilles à dessus
avec hanoi
hu a depuis les belles que nous y [ __ ]
je les aime encore plus deuxièmement il
est donc celui canton daniel avait mis
en avant dans un épisode de what the cut
oui j'ai vu les quenouilles bordel de
merde l'est encore plus troisièmement
c'est parti j'ai vu que ce quiz y avait
fait inviter au pour moi ça fait
longtemps je savais l'otan est un
moustique avait fait beau temps fait pas
johnny malgré cette blague je souhaite
toujours te poser j'ai vu que squeeze a
fait un vidéo pour moi et dans ce vidéo
et dit qu'il m'aime beaucoup et et que
je suis jolie
je suis très content à la croisade et
venu des partis que tu sais pas ce qu'il
a fait pour avoir faire inquiète mais
plus tard ces vidéos il fait jamais de
katia pas de broutage squeeze on
pourrait aller dans une église pour
mexique
pourquoi pas du rêve s'unir je pourrais
je pourrais tomber enceinte
johnny j'ai dit oui pour t'épouser mais
j'suis pas prêt pour l'enfant il faudra
plus de temps on parlera homme femme et
moi tu toi on te remettre des dégâts
d'eau à tous un bon exemple un squeeze
petit poucet nouvelle avec tout ce
qu'elle touche à sa fin c'est parce tu
veux m'épouser mois où le ce a pas moyen
d'un lumbago ont bousculé et jamin t et
vidéo pour la vie et tu es jolie qu'il
est sexy oui à mon ami mon bon squeeze
et c'est pas sur des ports transfert de
vidéos c'est de ne pas rire en fait le
prince tolérer que tu ne chantes pas tu
ne fait pas l'amour avec un sapin tu
arrêtes les chaunois stade donc tu
respectes les deux premières règles
je te remercie beaucoup ce beau vidéo
attendu le vrai déclic rsa ça sert
normalement ils ces foires et bien la
déception que la vie que sa présumée
on se bouffe vidéo
j'ai toujours rêvé de sentir le pq de
squeeze comme un chien on pourrait se
marier au mexique
tu l'as déjà dit johnny je te remercie
d'avoir partager vos vidéos
c'est une personne avec des bonnes des
bandes à leur merci de venise commencé à
+ tva plus vouloir l'épouser mais là ça
va ça remonte je vois ton regard qui
transperce mon regard g13 sa montée en
température et amis de la butte sur la
caméra johnny que je suis triste et je
crois qu'on fait tous les challenges à
quoi au fait essayez de ne pas rire et
essayer de ne pas être mal à l'aise
squeeze c'est squeeze je veux te
regarder dans les yeux et tu te dire des
mots sincères
alors je t'aime beaucoup de jonny
greenwood agents et johnny fait des
efforts pour nous pour finir et vidéos
squeeze j'aimerais beaucoup de
centenaires avec mon nez de jeunes
mahorais de lépinau sentir mais qui
tuent sans johnny jeulin technique à mon
frère pour tu sembles la presse et à
sentir les cheveux j'aimerais ça te
sentir le corps ce qu'elle me toi le
swing moi c'était un tir de poils non ça
fait partie des choses qu'on voulait pas
voir ôter vidéo j'aimerais se sentir
trop d'alcool dans les narines
weezy je veux te sentir c'est pas un
truc dans son caleçon que jodie là ça
craint
au charbon squeeze johnny je suis prêt
mais avec moi je n'y prends ma main
viens je t'emmène au mexique ont ma vie
on pourra se marier dans une église on
pourrait avoir une famille tu pourras me
sentir les cheveux et tout ce que tu
veux ou tonifier un joli je crois qu'il
se passe quelque chose entre nous
jeudi truites ont réagi